daniel tu m'as demandé de faire la paix
avec une personne j'ai essayé de la
joindre malheureusement cette mason
n'est plus
[Rires]
elle voit la considère que cette
personne est partie au pays oui
peut-être voilà il m'a pardonné voilà
exactement dans quel état pardonner ne
t'inquiète pas non mais c'est vrai on
embrasse maurice shudoo
146 cette adoption 17 non mais c'est
vrai ils sachent que dolla où il te
regarde voilà donc d'accord tout va bien
monsieur
savoir faire la paix il faut expliquer
le pourquoi du comment de la tension est
terminée par veux tu faire la paix avec
moi vous terminerez par veux tu faire la
paix avec moi et la personne concernée
utilisera soit le drapeau blanc pour
faire la paix soit le drapeau noir pour
dire nico book
[Rires]
première personne
gilles verdez oui avec qui voulez-vous
faire la paix avec delphine about
delphine pourquoi eu alors une tension
élevée ne sommes pas en conflit ouvert
mais c'est un conflit larvé qui n'avait
c'est à dire et qui mine toute l'équipe
l'art des wikis qui es tu en voilà comme
ça sous couvert de bonjour bonsoir il ya
un vrai conflit ouais et je ne suis pas
le seul dans ce cas mais moi car je vais
avoir le courage de demander pardon à
delphine delphine lorsque la saison
dernière vous avez pris des positions
très tranchées
nous vous avons laissé tomber j'ai
essayé cyril vous a soutenu j'ai essayé
de vous soutenir et vous m'avez dit un
jour mais gilles quand tu parlais bon
langage corporel de trahissait tu
n'avais pas l'air de croire en ce que tu
disais hé bien je m'en excuse j'ai pas
été assez claire delphine vous avez eu
le mérite de prendre des positions
claires forte et j'aurais dû plus être à
vos côtés maintenant je serai avec vous
est ce que je voulais vous dire delphine
avant que vous le viendra faut c'est que
si j'aborde ce sujet je suis méritants
de l'aborder parce que d'autres ici que
je ne nommerai pas parce que je ne
balance jamais personne
c'est un principe
[Applaudissements]
il
et si d'autres ici delphine continue
maintenant chaque fois que vous prenez
la parole à se moquer de vous en
coulisses ou sur le plateau a levé les
yeux au ciel donc en mon nom et au nom
de tous les autres qui sont des lâches
delphine mais pas de patrons des bars
[Applaudissements]
j'avais dit que je n'en aurai dit
puisque certains ont voulu m'interrompre
le pire de tous delphine sachez le kivu
moque ici en dehors il est venu vous
parler c'est mathieu de l'ombre
[Musique]
une terrine c'est vrai voulez-vous faire
la paix avec moi peut-être avec d'autres
mais en tout cas avec nommé déjà cj
alors il avait presque les drapeaux
noirs qui veut dire ni comme ou que j
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai que cette
période j'ai essayer de l'oublier et
j'ai plus ou moins réussis je vous le
rappelle
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est vrai que si je me si je me
remets dans cette période large que moi
delphine deux petites minutes durant je
dis un truc à la régie mais la musique
ne va pas
d'avoir un gars mondiale et ringard à
côté qui fait du sauvetage
conservatoire ya toujours un gars de
maximy nabro neeman c'est qu'ils jouent
comme
toujours avec 6 me en mono les a
balayées homme était
ta ils ont perdu hier dans l'ue
[Rires]
série
mais qui sont peu décalé qui sont
content c'est qu'ils aiment l'idée
comment ils peuvent trouver cette
musique qui tape quoi t'as pas sur
google c'est un message positif
car une telle carrière avec ces gens là
non mais je te jure mais il ya une
deuxième question comment j'ai pu faire
une telle carrière avec ces gens-là sers
toi normal entouré de partout partout
partout partout partout partout quoi
vous est peut-être c'était une
locomotive en accrocher à votre boule
derrière telle une carte
ouattara
alors qu'elle fine c'est très beau ce
que tu as dit gilles moi je trouve
vraiment oui non c'est très beau c'est
très beau et gilles donc tu soulèves
quand même et tu me tu me tues ravive
des souvenirs en moi et c'est vrai que à
cette période là où clairement tout le
monde m'avait lâché
je crois savoir que j'ai donné une
interview qui disait quand on a des
collègues comme ça on n'a pas besoin
d'ennemis alors tout simplement pour
cette période et à tous
[Applaudissements]
vous qui nous regarde et vous voyez que
cette journée de la paix commence
[Rires]
jean la semaine des
personnes aux deux soeurs hypothèque g
berne est tellement fou c'est une chose
à me dire moi peut-être prendre l
rattrap aux planches je sais pas
j'essaye pourtant ni comme bouc voilà
donc abou dhabi non comme monde pour
voir on va passer à la 2e réconciliation
peut-être enfin deuxième réconciliation
tard aujourd'hui vous voyez c'est la
journée internationale de la paix
deuxième personne c'est jean michel
maire encore oui avec si vous vous
appelez bien jean michel mercier envoyez
vite et
j'ai douté mathus avait grillé ou jean
pons a rebondi quand il y est attendez
attendez attendez
genton le loup le renard
on a la même qu'il achetait ses cuisses
ouais c'est la même ouais
donc guillaume on était très proche un
moment c'est vrai on sortait ensemble
même souche de tout
[Applaudissements]
le monde a
bien joué a joué aucun rôle à celle
inverse c'est moi qui laissait tomber
voilà je me suis un peu éloigné de
guillaume parce que c'est vrai qu'on
sortait on se voyait en dehors et on a
les mêmes dans des endroits dans des
clubs dont
est elle même très bon dans les méandres
de la mi temps j'ai fini par ne plus
l'inviter ou ne plus me joindre à lui
dans de la bien fait de sortir de là
dans ce genre de soirée c'est comme il y
en a qui sont fans de l'application tik
tok lui un autre toc c'est plutôt le bit
tokyo du coup je me suis vite
reviendront dans des jeux lui présenter
une meuf qui ajuste une vraiment bravo
fait vraiment un très
très bon retour de m on me le fait tout
ce qu'on ne veut pas alors allons-y oui
et à chaque je me suis rendu compte qu'à
chaque fois que je présentais une meuf
il là qu'est né et après il a bloqué sur
son téléphone mais pour vous je me suis
fâché avec des copines à moi qui m'ont
dit mais c'est qui cet ignoble
personnage que tu nous a présenté et
c'est la saison t'es chez moi on entend
ce que tu dis là
[Applaudissements]
c'est complet tu sais que six mois de
ses coûts passent à la téloche il ya des
gens qui nous regardent je viens de
mener une personne qui nous regardent
c'est un ami mais je pense que dois je
pense qu'il a alors à moi oui mais je
pense qu'il a surtout envie d'être amie
avec moi je pense que les autres s'en
fut exactement qui compte et je pense
qu'il peut te répondre tout de suite
c'est vraiment à ça jean-mi franchement
non mais je suis touché parce que j'ai
envie c'est une belle personne que
j'aime beaucoup c'est pour ça que j'ai
envie de t'adresser un grand ni comme on
dit chez moi qui me présente des films
de vomir dessus
c'est vrai qu'au lieu d'en manger de
tout savoir et la troisième personne qui
veut faire la paix c'est béatrice
béatrice rosen l'américaine 6 chez ou un
tube et de piss
christ oui géraldine mais on dirait
vraiment la porte dont les vers la
mecque pièce oui une étoile les seuils
avait mis six gars et moi je me rappelle
que j'avais ok ok 6e c'était en mai mais
si ce gars est mister garrett est
toujours un mec là peter l'aps vous avez
des parts des congrès des correspondants
ouais amélie jouera correspondant vous
savez il ya déjà des vies comme ça on
allait des correspondants qui venait oui
je m'en rappelle j'en avais un vrai j'ai
failli s'appeler peter il est à la
maison et je lui disais de dire que des
gros mois ma mère m'a
dit que si celui-là est dit que des gros
mots bon c'est vrai un jury l'arrivée de
jean sébastien bach te faire [ __ ]
ça ou je suis là je te jure que c'est
vrai et à chaque fois je le prenais des
gros mots mon père entre elles soit à sa
place face au poiré le merde
[Applaudissements]
il a pris déplaire à part mes parents
lynch aurait eu un monsieur quand ap ap
les autres si j'avais encore mal c'est
le bas l'angleterre une famille et les
parents actifs lik ha oui ça faisait une
rover que voiture donc le matin et le
déposer à l'école en octobre pauliste
est offert dans mon correspondant c'est
peter thériault l'on attend aussi plus
tard je corresponds salle et peter il
était était hyper mignon et moi j'avais
un petit coup de coeur tu vois qu'elle a
16 ans je pense à lui en troisième c'est
la bonne
c'est sa troisième seconde avait 16 ans
et était très très beau et on en a eu le
champ musée pas hésité paris chaste et
flic et on aime chambrer tout ça est
montré hyper joli mais je ne sais pas
genre lui prendre la main et pas exclure
du circuit toi c'était pas évident quand
même mais j'en un très très beau sur
peut-être que si ça trouve il l'était
aussi est-ce que je répare la paix la
peter peut-être je sais pas si oui alors
people il était aussi hier alors qu'il
est là il est à l'enterrement de
il devoir 45 ans aujourd'hui 48 ans je
sais pas et lance un appel ta jamais
battu peter est loin de tout faux cul ou
rideau ça parle anglais je parle anglais
aujourd'hui qu'elle n'avait rien dit sam
avec les réseaux sociaux tu pourrais le
retrouve sur i do me fait plaisir de
montauban peter c'est tout habitat s'est
retrouvé des guerres on est passé à côté
de nice tort de sartrouville et surtout
morts béatrice alors j'ai fait un
français
elle a pris le test ainsi
passé deux jours dans le massachusetts
paris 6 nov alors géraldine tu sais que
la saison précédente on a eu un petit un
gros différend même sur l'histoire des
vaccins toute la politique sanitaire du
gouvernement tu as
[Musique]
tu m'as balancé une belle claque virtuel
un jour où j'étais à cette place
d'ailleurs c'est toute l'histoire si je
suis j'ai rien compris alors on avait un
différend sur les champs les vaccins
n'étaient pas d'accord elle n'aimait pas
mes opinions elle m'a traitée de folle
voire de complotiste et de plein
d'autres noms d'oiseaux elle m'a dit
qu'elle préférerait que ce soit son ami
qui soit à cette place et je m'en aille
le plus vite possible
qui doit nous regardent et nawa
allez valérie
niquet nommé tet e power
by nicolas chambre à ce soit
la paire nikos ce que j'ai vu en restant
non vous l'avez reconnu ce midi non pas
du tout non il m'a envoyé un petit texto
genre ouais je te vois un way à la télé
sinon on restaurant là et je suis allé
le voir à la fin une magnifique île à
une chevelure magnifique jeudi qu'il
allait revenir cette semaine dans
l'émission ça fait deux ans que l'état
fait de revenir ça
va revenir ah ouais je pense que
vendredi il sera là non ouais je vous
n'êtes pas là si
jamais il sera là nicolas pernikoff je
dirais pour ma viendra pas seul une
belle promesse nous peut-être spectacle
viendra avec son américaine
[Applaudissements]
gbagbo alors béatrice j'aimerais finir
pour tout ce que tu as que ce que
géraldine me réservera comme drapeau et
donc voilà je m a été un petit peu fort
mais mme mathieu on avait eu le souffle
coupé baptisé
battue
c'est juste à mykonos oulé tia
deviennent plus benhaim mais
elle avait en gros un petit peu utilisé
d'une position dominante étant donné que
j'étais nouvelle dans l'émission mais
bon passons on a eu un épisode dans une
piscine où on a eu 1 on a partagé un
baiser et je pensais que c'était une
démarche visant à nous réconcilier
lorsque depuis plus rien non pas que tu
croises
6 mai et ne lui a pas plu aux j'avais
envoyé quoi tu croyais que c'était pour
un happening à
partir en cacahuète m'a donné n'est ce
pas donc ben apparemment un l'amérique
l'amérique je veux la voir en
plus d'hétéros ont été mises
et donc bref je voulais savoir
géraldine si tu voulais qu'on fasse
réellement la paix mais pas une peine de
deux façades nos paies de porcelaine
véritable voilà et accepter nos
différences et
et notionnel dans cette surprise parce
que je pensais que quand on s'était
embrassé fougueusement dans cette
piscine ben en fait la paix était déjà
scellé on est destiné donc oui moi
j'adore le débat enflammé je suis
jusqu'au boutiste chante hier j'ai
beaucoup de différence entre une
noisette mais encore une fois je n'ai
aucune espèce de rancoeur ou d'amertume
et surtout je suis pas du tout
rancunière donc il y avait aucun
problème donc comme tu américaine et
comme je crois dans la contre culture
américaine y avait un slogan c'est
faites l'amour pas la guerre bat
allons-y mais quand
elle conservait pas s'être imposé nation
quand un deuxième baiser
m
attendez je m'occupe de la musique donne
les bonnes choses cyril nom mais qui
juge béatrice qu'en penses tu non dans
l'intimité peut-être le nom médias
pendant tout l'été
la piscine c'était un décor plus propice
que jeter de
la paix la piscine olympique si c'est
possible
ça me coûte sa mort il a urait typhon
régie pour certains trucs
[Applaudissements]
mais sans déconner mais moi je joue je
trouve personnellement faites ce que
vous voulez moi je suis pas là pour
pousser la consommation non
vous faites ce que vous voulez mais mais
c'est vrai que comme vous l'avez dit ce
baiser a marqué un nouveau départ
ne repasserait non pas par la case
départ ne toucheront pas la dernière
aime encore vingt mille
selena je les ai pas touché mais non
plus moi
non c'est comme vous voulez géraldine
composants mais je veux pas forcé
donc non mais je redis mais après ça l'a
dit ouvert c'était le premier pas de
douala dont l'accès est le deuxième pape
est ce qu'on pensait que troisième
au revoir paribas propose une étreinte
comme influent
away il faut pas trop ce qu'elle veut
elle pense que mes déroule à vous faites
connaître définir un petit peu c'est
comme un baiser de cinéma ont levé vous
[Applaudissements]
le jour
de faire la paix définitive
c'est bon et maintenant cyr et les
moellons nous réconcilier
on m'a d'abord la page avec témoignant
d'un on n'a jamais été fâché
sera jamais tranchée mais j'ai mes
vaches et non parce que surtout pas
envie de me réconcilier c'est bon tu
vois pas on a on a bravo les deux
favoris
[Applaudissements]
celle qui aura fait la paix ce soir
c'est pas d'exemple le monde nous
exactement c'est pas c'est pas fini il
ya une dernière personne qui veut
se réconcilie avec une autre personne
oui c'est toi guillaume oui bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir oui bonsoir oui
ça va ma gueule lui et toi je souhaite
me réconcilie avec daniel moreau a le
bisou
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que j'ai passé l'année
dernière à lui tendre une perche c'est
vrai mais j'ai arrêté par des oui non
mais parce que j'arrêtais pas de la
draguer je suis proposé des week-ends
des massages aux pierres chaudes et
j'avais promis à la fin de ce week-end
peut-être de la bouillabaisse en respect
en fait ce qui m'a fait de la peine
c'est qu'évidemment enfin pour moi
c'était une blague et gilles m'a dit un
jour que daniel avait pris ça très au
sérieux et je crois que j'avais
développé quelques sentiments daniel
c'est ce que m'a dit ça m'a fait de la
peine c'est pas si c'est vrai mais en
fait ouais c'est un peu douloureux mais
c'est vrai que tu avais l'air sincère un
moment j'ai cru au début on arrête de
nous non mais c'est vrai
quand on est on sait pas crédible non
mais quand on met dans le désert comme
moi de l trop longtemps on s'accroche à
n'importe quelle gourde donc je m'étais
[Applaudissements]
le désert j'ai cru un moment franchement
parce qu'on avait un accent de sincérité
c'est vrai donc donc voilà donc je suis
tombé un peu de haut ats sincère non
mais en fait voilà je voulais m'excuser
parce que je ne cherche pas l'amour pour
l'instant où pour le week-end et le sexe
éventuellement
[Rires]
alors est ce que ton idée déjà nombreux
j'aimerais bien visiter son goal imagine
10e brocante mais non c'est ici la
brocante
[Applaudissements]
pour le week end romantique c'est mort
en revanche daniel sache que je serai
toujours là pour toi et que je te
d'exemple quand tu veux
[Applaudissements]
mon cochon
c'est pas des surpasse déjà
merci dirai jamais ça tu es content
regardez
je frétille alors les chéris il nous
reste maintenant deux minutes aurait
deux minutes chacun va me dire quelque
chose en 15 secondes je dirais à chaque
frappe aux blancs ou nico book mais sur
qui me concerne 1 1 vous me demandez ce
que vous voulez à vous avez chacun 20
secondes qui veut des maris 20 secondes
chacun 6 à 19h12 on n'avait rien demandé
c'est terminé je clôture on peut joindre
aux coréens ont presque rien demandé à
bien alors attention si vous ne répondez
jamais un message quand je vous appelle
c'est le désert mais là j'ai une vraie
sollicitations et fatouma compagne par
les sentiments si jamais on se marie ce
qui va survenir bientôt est-ce que vous
viendrez oui ou non parce que je n'y
crois nous le
[Applaudissements]
dit jean michel way to tous les matins
moi j'attends un coup de téléphone de
l'aide de la rédaction savoir sur quoi
il faut bosser et j'ai un problème
téléphone qui est complètement sa
l'iphone 6 qui est complètement fou tu
devrais savoir si vous auriez
l'amabilité a pour des raisons
professionnelles de mme auffret à des
derniers iphone
[Applaudissements]
il aura accumulé tout est vraiment à
vous le savez j'habite moi je vais en
voiture je suis un peu en scooter dans
la place de boîtes de passe de quick se
grattent de parking c'est non c'est non
c'est non c'est non allez allez allez me
dire des promesses des promesses vous me
promettez si on mettait tout boutabout
des week-ends tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
tu sais pas sb oui elle a dit le nom est
ce qu'on mettra la bûche dans la
cheminée avant noël
on va passer une soirée ensemble et une
nuits semaine prochaine rené ce
we mathieu à la promo de ce mini
puisqu'on y est
c'est fait quatre ans que vous tournez
autour de moi tel un paon ou aller où
[Applaudissements]
tellement qu'elle rompt une eau du coup
de gay libérer toute l'eau et oui ça
fait quatre ans également que malgré la
passion qui m'anime pour ce métier nous
n'avons pas été augmentés penser
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on passe de moins en moins de temps
ensemble j'aime bien qu'on se rapproche
et que pour les prochaines vacances au
bac à dubaï
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien être
votre petit michto à dubaï et vous
fassiez dans votre cape iv quoi vous
fassiez l'amour dans votre cabinet à
plus de 4,4 j'ai peut-être mais je peux
te faire l'amour à côté dans quatre cas
importés voilà merci terminé vraiment à
bout je fais leur libre-arbitre et vinet
est ce que je pourrais avoir une
trottinette électrique merci
[Applaudissements]
vous avez donné une idée une fois qui
s'appelait le world d'arc à tour les
mercis
[Applaudissements]